IT'S ALL YOURS.
>> Laura: JASON, FANTASTIC JOB
AS ALWAYS, GREAT TO SEE YOU AND
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS IS
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE.
GLOBALISTS ARE ON THE RUN, THUS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THEY TOLD US IT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL.
>> I BELIEVE WE CAN MAKE OUR
ECONOMY EVEN STRONGER AND MAKE
OPEN TRADE AN EVEN GREATER FORCE
FOR PEACE AND PROSPERITY IN THE
NEW CENTURY.
>> KEEPING AMERICA COMPETITIVE
REQUIRES US TO OPEN MORE MARKETS
FOR ALL.
>> I BELIEVE THE PROCESS OF
GLOBALIZATION IS HERE TO STAY,
THERE ARE A ENORMOUS BENEFITS TO
BE GAINED FROM THAT OF GLOBAL
INTEGRATION.
>> Laura: THEY TRASH THE
POPULIST OPPOSITION.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A POPULIST
AND POPULISM CAN BE A VERY
DANGEROUS TOOL.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> THE LARGER PROBLEM IS A
POPULIST, RACIST KNOW NOTHING
MOVEMENT THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
INCONSISTENT WITH DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: THAT WAS ALL WISHFUL
THINKING.
FROM SUPPLY CHAIN NIGHTMARES TO
FOOD AND FUEL SHORTAGES THE
POINTLESS WARS, MASSIVE REFUGEE
CRISES, THE WHEELS HAVE BEEN
COMING OFF THE GLOBALIZATION
TRAIN.
THE MEDIA HATES TO REPORT ON
THIS BUT ONE OF THE BIG STORIES
PLAYING OUT OVER THE SUMMER IS
THE RISE OF THE FREEDOM
MOVEMENT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT NORMAL PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD WHO ARE PUSHING
BACK ON THE GLOBALIST AGENDA
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY DOMINATING
OUR POLITICS SINCE THE 1990s.
TOO OFTEN WE ARE TOLD THAT IT'S
AMERICANS, THEY ARE THE ONLY
ONES WHO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
GLOBALIZATION AND WHAT IT MEANS
FOR OUR CULTURE AND OUR ECONOMY
AND WAY OF LIFE.
AROUND THE WORLD, WORKING PEOPLE
ARE NOW PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE
SYSTEM THAT IS MAKING A SMALL
SLIVER OF THE POPULATION VERY
RICH WHILE HARMING THE INTERESTS
OF THE VAST MAJORITY.
IF I TOLD YOU FOR EXAMPLE THAT
FARMERS WHO ARE FURIOUS ABOUT
HIGH COSTS AND REGULATIONS WERE
MARCHING AGAINST GOVERNMENT
CLIMATE FANATICS, HE WOULD
PROBABLY THINK IT WAS HAPPENING
SOMEWHERE IN RURAL AMERICA BUT
AS WE REPORTED LAST NIGHT IT'S
HAPPENING IN THE NETHERLANDS.
>> THE FARMERS WANT A STABLE
FUTURE, THEY WANT A STABLE
FUTURE.
THEY BUY THE FARM AND THEY ARE
DRAWN.
>> YOU TOLD ME EARLIER THEY HAVE
NO FUTURE AND THEY WERE HANGING
THEMSELVES, IS THAT SOMETHING
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF AND A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW?
>> YES.
IT IS A CRISIS.
>> Laura: THE ATTACK ON
FARMING AND AGRICULTURE IS
TERRIFYING AND IT'S ALL
ACCORDING TO THE GLOBALIST
PLAYBOOK.
IN FRANCE, VOTERS REJECTED
EMMANUEL MACRON'S AGENDA BY
GIVING MORE POWER TO LEFT-WING
AND RIGHT-WING PARTIES.
HIS SUPPORT FOR THE WAR IN
UKRAINE WAS CITED REPEATEDLY BY
BOTH OPPOSITION CANDIDATES.
THEY SEIZED ON RECORD LEVEL
INFLATION TO PORTRAY HIM AS A
LEADER WHO PAYS MORE ATTENTION
TO HIS ROLE IN DIPLOMATIC STAGE
THEN TO VOTERS STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET.
IN GERMANY WITH THE GLOBALIST
AGENDA WAS ONCE A FRONT AND
CENTER FOR THE WORLD TO SEE,
THEY HAVE ESSENTIALLY HAD TO
ADMIT TO THE WHOLE THING IS A
FAILURE.
PUTTING THE ENTIRE COUNTRY INTO
A SELF-INFLICTED ENERGY CRISIS.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
THEY ARE MOVING BACK -- THEY ARE
BRINGING BACK COAL.
IN BRITAIN, BORIS JOHNSON CAME
TO POWER BECAUSE HE WAS ONE OF
THE FEW POLITICIANS WHO WOULD
IMPLEMENT BREXIT, HE ENDED UP
GETTING DISTRACTED BY GLOBALIST
CONCERNS AS WELL AND HE
PRESENTED HIMSELF AS SOMEONE WHO
IS GOING TO FOCUS ON THE WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE BUT THEN HE BECAME
ENAMORED BY CHINA AND THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND
CHINA IS A GREAT COUNTRY, IT'S
GOING TO BE A GIGANTIC FACTOR OF
THE WORLD ECONOMY FOR A LONG
TIME TO COME.
>> LET ME SAY NO TO THE PEOPLE
OF UKRAINE THAT I KNOW WE IN THE
U.K. WILL CONTINUE TO BACK YOUR
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM FOR AS LONG AS
IT TAKES.
>> Laura: THE GLOBALISTS
ROUTINELY ARGUE THAT ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THE IDEA OF OPEN
MARKETS AND OPEN BORDERS, THAT
THEY ARE DESTABILIZING THE
GLOBAL SYSTEM BUT THE TRUTH IS
IT'S GLOBALIZATION ITSELF THAT
IS DESTABILIZING AN END
WEAKENING GREAT WESTERN NATIONS
THAT HAVE EXISTED FOR CENTURIES.
LET'S BE REAL -- ALMOST ALL OF
US AT THIS POINT YOU KNOW WHO
THE REAL WINNER IN THE
GLOBALIZATION GAME IS.
OF COURSE, HE AGGRESSIVELY
DEFENDS THE SYSTEM AGAINST ANY
AND ALL CRITICS.
>> ITS TRUE ECONOMIC
GLOBALIZATION HAS CREATED NEW
PROBLEMS.
BUT THIS IS NO JUSTIFICATION TO
WRITE OFF ECONOMIC GLOBALIZATION
ALTOGETHER.
RATHER, WE SHOULD ADAPT TO
ECONOMIC GLOBALIZATION.
>> Laura: IRONICALLY OF
COURSE, XI IS THE BIGGEST
NATIONALIST OF ALL THREATENING
ANYONE OR ANY COUNTRY THAT KITS
IN ITS WAY.
AS CHINA DID RECENTLY WITH
AUSTRALIA WHEN IT'S AIR FORCE
WAS MERELY CONDUCTING ROUTINE
MISSIONS OVER INTERNATIONAL
WATERS.
OF COURSE WHEN PUSH COMES TO
SHOVE ON ALMOST EVERY ISSUE, THE
POLITICAL BUSINESS AND MEDIA
ESTABLISHMENT HERE, THEY AGREE
WITH THE CCP I THINK PRETTY MUCH
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
THEY DON'T JUST AGREE WITH THEM,
THEY END UP REWARDING CHINA.
WE HAVE A SHOCKING DEVELOPMENT
ON THAT FRONT INVOLVING HUNTER
BIDEN, WE WILL BRING YOU IN JUST
A FEW MOMENTS.
IN THE GLOBALIST WORLDVIEW IT'S
TOTALLY LOGICAL FOR THEM TO
CRITICIZE AND PUNISH STATES HERE
LIKE FLORIDA AND MISSISSIPPI
WENT ACCORDING TO THE ELITES
THEY ARE NOT LIVING UP TO THE
MODERN NORMS, ABORTION, TRENDS
RIGHTS, ET CETERA.
NOTHING THAT HAPPENS INSIDE
CHINA MATTERS OF THE GLOBALISTS.
NOT THE UIGHURS BEING TORTURED,
NOT DISSIDENTS IN PRISON, NOT
CHILD LABOR, NOT HONG KONG,
THEIR FREEDOM BEING SMASHED,
CERTAINLY NOT THE COVID
LOCKDOWNS, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
ANY OF THAT TO.
HIGH FLYERS AND BUSINESS AND
POLITICS JUST SIGNED A LETTER
URGING PRESIDENT BIDEN TO SEEK
MORE COOPERATION AND
ACCOMMODATION WITH CHINA.
NONE OF THEM HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
GETTING THEIR JOBS OFFSHORE TO
CHINA BUT COURTESY OF
GLOBALIZATION, CHINA HAS THE
POWER, THE MONEY, AND THE
PRESTIGE TO BULLY THE
UNITED STATES WHEN IT'S BEING
RUN BY AN INCOMPETENT BUNCH LIKE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEIR ANSWER TO THAT?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BASICALLY IS SAYING THANK YOU,
SIR, MAY I HAVE ANOTHER?
BIDEN IS CLOSE TO LIFTING TRUMPS
TARIFFS ON CHINESE GOODS AND
JANET YELLEN'S MEETING WITH HER
COUNTERPART AND ANTONY BLINKEN
WITH HIS THIS WEEK, NOTHING GOOD
IS GOING TO COME OUT OF THAT.
GOOFBALL JOHN KERRY STILL THINKS
CHINA IS GOING TO BE A KEY ALLY
IN FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE, THIS
IS HILARIOUS.
CHINA IS MOVING FULL STEAM AHEAD
WITH COAL AND ITS OWN REFINING
CAPACITY, BUILDING THAT UP HUGE.
THINGS ARE SO BAD, AMERICA IS SO
WEAKENED, A STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL ACTUALLY IS QUOTED
TODAY AS SAYING AMERICA SHOULD
ESSENTIALLY ABANDON ASIA TO
CHINA, THAT IS DANGEROUS FOR
WASHINGTON TO DETER A CHINESE
ATTACK ON TAIWAN, WE NEED TO BE
INVESTING MORE IN ECONOMIC
ENGAGEMENT AND COUNTERING
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE COOPERATION WITH CHINA.
WHO CARES ABOUT TAIWAN, THAT IS
OVERRATED.
LET'S KEEP POURING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THE UKRAINE FOREVER.
IF WE'RE GOING TO WIN THIS
DEBATE, WE ARE ALREADY WAITING
THIS DEBATE AND IN 2024 THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
THAT ABOVE ALL ELSE THE AMERICAN
PRESIDENT THIS TIME AS HE WAS IN
2016, HIS WHOLE CABINET WILL P